next question today hey David after
Donald Trump is gone whether it's in two
years or six years how long will it take
for the United States to be respected
again depends who you ask
okay so trumpets believe that the United
States is more respectable now under
Donald Trump than it ever was under
President Barack Obama now that happens
to run counter to the facts and what we
know about world opinion of the United
States under Bush where it was down
under Obama were recovered and now under
Donald Trump where it is low and it's
not just opinion for the sake of opinion
when public opinion is low when we are
no longer respected by the world leaders
around the world including at our
so-called allies like Canada and France
and Germany in the UK this is not just a
problem ideologically it's a problem
geopolitically it's a problem when it
comes to national security and it's a
problem economically as well okay
economically when the u.s. is not
respected around the world because the
president is a laughingstock travel
struggles and we're seeing that as it is
the number of companies and
organizations around the world that say
let's look to the US for the cutting
edge on green energy or the cutting edge
on whatever technology that doesn't
happen and that's not good for the
United States economically when it comes
to world leaders the serious
conversations about a growing number of
issues around the world no longer
include the United States because
Trump's presence wouldn't be good and
what's he gonna do send Ivanka as he's
been doing before that's not good either
so on issues like climate change we see
that increasingly Donald Trump after
announcing that he's pulling the United
States out of the Paris climate Accords
he's not even invited to many of the
serious discussions about what to do
with the climate I mean after all he
said climate change is a hoax developed
by China in order to bolster their
manufacturing industry when it comes to
dealing with geopolitical issues that
involve countries
that seemed to have Trump over a barrel
like Russia like Saudi Arabia the United
States more and more is not a player
another sort of crossover geopolitical
and economic impact of Donald Trump not
being respected and the u.s. not being
respected respected is the move away
from the dollar we've seen a lot of
major powers China Russia others who are
moving away from the dollar as a reserve
currency as a trading currency the
tariffs that Donald Trump put in place
then waited on putting in place
additional ones in China because the
negotiations were going well even though
it seems that they actually weren't we
don't really know what's going on in any
case all of that is hurting the US
dollar so all of these things are going
to take a long time there is so much you
know at the beginning I would say some
of these executive orders are not really
doing anything they are just statements
of support from the administration for a
particular point of view or a particular
perspective or whatever and they can be
undone because they don't really do
anything we're well beyond that the
economic repercussions the repercussions
in terms of how our allies see us it's
going to be years I don't want to say it
will be a full presidential term after
Trump is gone but it's not going to be
new American president is sworn in and
three weeks later everything is back to
the way it was it's not going to be that
way with our alliances and relationships
with other countries and it's not going
to be that way economically either it's
going to take a while to make up for
this